[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in
pat 40 covers the sport had a lot of
things to say about bob baffert
after the kentucky derby uh pat had a
tweet saying maryland officials cite
integrity of due process and allowing
medina spirit to run while
also asking for additional testing of
the derby winner
testing yesterday and today should yield
results by friday
officials said uh pat i said this after
the derby i said it to bob baffert why
don't they test
the horses prior to the derby then you
don't have this embarrassment
and he said well it's hard to do that if
you do it friday and then the race is
saturday can you get the test results
well
the preakness is doing this now and
medina's spirit is
going to be racing here so what do you
make of the preakness medina spirit and
bob baffert
yeah i i guess i'm not surprised that
medina spirit uh has been
given the tentative go-ahead to race
we'll see what the drug test comes back
with on friday if there's still
uh traces of beth medizone in his in his
system or not but
i i just think that without the second
confirming sample
back from churchill downs that they were
facing
you know a lot of angry lawyering if
they tried to keep the horse out of
the preakness here and quite frankly you
know as you alluded to you
don't want to run a preakness without
the derby winner if it's controversial
well
maybe all so much the better for a race
that really is lacking any luster dan i
mean
this is a weak field other than medina
spirit and baffert's other horse concert
tour
so if you're pimlico racecourse maryland
jockey club you're sitting there saying
yeah we want that horse yeah the uh
the head veterinarian uh at pimlico
said the following this morning if there
is or was any
of this drug or any other medications
whether therapeutic or illegal in the
horse we will know about that before the
race
this is supposed to be therapeutic this
cream that was put on this horse
so why is it considered cheating
if it's not something that really in you
know it's not a performance enhancing
drug
yeah well i mean is it as an
anti-inflammatory
i would think it falls into the category
of something that relieves discomfort
for horses and thus
is it relieving a discomfort that would
otherwise keep them from running as well
or running at all
if without that uh it's not the first
baffert horse to test positive for this
demean
uh is brilliantly fast philly tested for
this last year
in the kentucky oaks so what was the
purpose of using it then you know are
is there is it being used simply as a
topical for an and
a skin irritation or is it you being
used to alleviate pain
or discomfort in some other area that's
i think the question
i wondered if bob baffert didn't go all
scorched earth
a couple of days ago that we might be a
little bit more lenient because he had
cancer culture
he had sabotage i mean denials
never used it we don't use this and then
i i said to bob bob did you do inventory
here did you ask
people who work with you he said we're
in the process
don't you start with the veterinarian i
mean i don't understand this pat
i i don't no i'm with you that exactly
i mean if they found out about this on
saturday
i mean the first call goes to the vet
doesn't it if if you are you know 100 in
the clear the first call
is there any chance to why this horse
would have this in its system
and you go go from there to everybody
else in your barn
you know why would the horse test
positive for this and
yeah i think bob's reaction uh
definitely was off-putting to some
people and just the
the cumulative effect of this has been
you know five
very high profile positive tests for bob
baffert horses
uh you know he's great for the sport in
terms of
his success and his visibility and his
approachability
uh he's glib you know he's recognizable
in a sport where nobody's recognizable
but at the same time he's lost a lot of
credibility in the last year plus
really over these drug tests and i think
this was like one bridge too many for a
lot of people
did horse racing have a good week
no i don't think so now i mean you could
argue you know as your lead in said any
publicity is good for listening but
they're testing the bounds of that for
sure
i don't think so anytime the kentucky
derby winner is disqualified
that's a bad week now it has certainly
sustained the storyline of medina spirit
and what and the kentucky derby for
several days and it's
it's brought interest into the preakness
that maybe wouldn't be there
but i don't think i think what we're
gonna have we're gonna have people at
pimlico booing the medina spirit
and you know while that may not hurt the
horse's feelings
it's not necessarily good for the sport
the horse hasn't apologized technically
yes he's
not he's been stubbornly silenced yes
yes he has uh thanks for joining us pat
we appreciate your time as always
my pleasure dan that's pat forty sports
illustrated senior writer